today we have Camille Ricketts from
first round and so much oxy from a 16z
and we have a ton of questions about
content content marketing editorial from
Twitter so I think what's just gonna
jump right into him okay good cool
so adore Chung partner YC asked two
questions first of which is how do you
measure the effectiveness of your
content sonal you're asking me first oh
my god I'm gonna give you guys a cop-out
answer which is because I think content
measurements like one of the hardest
things that has not been solved and I've
been looking for tools and things for
years and you know in media you have
like obvious things like page views and
time on site but I think the number one
question is you have to really tie it to
what you're trying to do and I know that
sounds like a really obvious thing but
actually people don't stop to pause and
ask themselves like what are we trying
to measure and why like what's how does
it fit our strategy and our goal and
then also what you measure is what
you're actually going to bother changing
because why measure something if you're
really not gonna do anything about it
and so things that I value most are
things like time on site engagement and
uptake much more than pageviews but of
course it is kind of a nice high when
you get a lot of people reading
something in sort of make that more
specific what is like a good time on
site that you're looking for do you like
base it on the word count of an article
of a video what do you do
ya know there's no it's not an arbitrary
number for sure because I have a I
actually have a big pet peeve around
word lengths like I hate when people get
into religious debates around length
like short is good bad as long as bad or
people only do this and I hate all those
rules do you guys have word counts on
your staffer we don't have word counts
what we write extremely long yes we can
a lot of people saying why are you doing
that yeah it really depends on the
content you're trying to share so
exactly yeah that's what I hate as a
religious debate around it because
that's exactly it like what is the
amount of length that you actually need
to convey the point and so it's more
about information density to me like how
many insights are you conveying like not
like per square foot but you know what I
mean like you know are you really
packing it in or just like you're just
meandering for no reason
and so the lengthing so to go back to
your point about the measurement like
there isn't an actual number because it
depends on the length you know a 4,000
word piece is gonna take ten minutes to
read but you get a sense and I know that
seems like a cop-out but you do get a
sense like this is a piece that has high
engagement like a lot of people are
actually really staying with it they're
not just flipping in and out and I don't
know the tools you guys use but I still
use chart B even though you know we
don't have to use chart because you
don't get that kind of traffic like you
do an immediate but it does kind of tell
you where people drop off and I think
that data literally informed how I think
about writing and editing and how I
think about being an editor mmm because
you really pay attention at keeping
people hooked for every turn at least in
the first third of a piece before
they're committed right so are you
mixing it up with like pull quotes like
images what do you guys do they're
definitely good at that okay because you
guys have a really beautifully designed
I really like the look and I know I
really genuinely like the look and feel
of what you guys yeah when we redesign
the site we really wanted to focus on
readability because we do write quite
long so how can you keep someone reading
really engaged and the types of things
that we found to be most effective as
subheads obviously in order to give
people sort of trail markers that a
piece that they can literally skip ahead
to the content that they might be
looking for in particular but then also
pull quotes that keep them feeling the
voiceover the person that we're
featuring because that's a huge part of
the appeal we think is that you feel
sort of this conversational tone of the
person being interviewed so both of
those tricks have made a big difference
and then also bulleting as much content
as we can
numbering as much content if you give
people a sense of like how much they can
anticipate from a certain section
they're more likely to read it because
they're like oh I feel like that's going
to be digestible and so knowing that
people make those types of calculations
and feeding into it has been really I
totally agree with you and we don't use
pull quotes as much because in our
content which is I think a slight
difference is that because you guys do
more reported voices and ours is the
first-person voice we don't do as many
pull quotes but I do think it's a great
feature but we'd totally do the scanning
and subhead thing and I totally agree
with you and in fact one
the tricks that I love is when you can
actually kind of make the subheads tell
the story but I'm going to read the
piece but you have to reveal just the
right amount to kind of give you the
info sent for what you're getting but
not so much that you're giving all the
goodies away so people think okay I can
just can the subhead to not read the
piece like there's sort of like a
balancing act there but I I completely
agree with you about that that's such a
great design thing yeah we kind of break
all the rules of like English 101 we're
like you know paragraph opener closer
absolutely two sentences long pressed by
yes well in fact on the English 101
thing when my other thing is that you
know I know there's a whole rule in
journalism on the inverted pyramid and
you know and I agree when you edit
academics experts especially they always
have a huge buildup before you even know
why you're writing I'm a big big
believer in in that graph like in fact
when you know in the net graph is sort
of like the nut shell paragraph I'm only
saying this for you guys all know what
that is but like you know I've had to
actually I had to explain it also
because we spell it nut graph and utg
RAF and people are like what's the nut
graph because I keep saying it but it
does matter to have that because you
need a place to anchor people right away
and for argument pieces I really
strongly believe you need an argument
net graph like the argument is not
conveyed by having a very provocative
headline and just assuming people are
gonna read and I like to have a rule of
thumb but I like them nut graph to come
in about a by the third paragraph it
doesn't have to be there it's a classic
journal that's one of the journalism
rules I don't mind keeping actually but
I don't like the classic inverted
pyramid like I actually like nonlinear
narrative sometimes that don't follow
like a perfect five point essay you know
like mess with it it's fun to have fun
with content absolutely absolutely
especially when you're doing volume
right you can track like what works what
doesn't
yeah I mean I will say that um sometimes
like you can tell what works but I think
it's hard to pinpoint I mean just be
blunt it's such a hard you need a lot of
data points you do like just because
people responded a certain way to a type
of thing you did in a certain piece you
can't really make a conclusion exactly
that that's gonna apply to everything
cuz it's like N equals one logically it
might have worked for that piece but
it's not gonna work for every other
piece like that like we had this thing
happen where
everyone's like oh my god these
explainers work well let's do more
explainers but I'm like it's not the
explainer that worked well it's a fact
that it was an explainer with an
argument built in total it's not just
saying AI you know right here's how a AI
works and deep learning and machine
learning the argument was why it's an AI
spring and given that there were so many
pass AI winters there wasn't a length
that you have and there's so many
variables like it could be the topic it
could be the people that are speaking
about this exact you don't really know
unless you've tried something
consistently across many many different
versions I have to say I'm dying to hear
your answer on their measurement
question yeah no I'm waiting for it to
yeah I mean I would do all of that like
so often I think like oh this is gonna
be a good one
and it's just like yeah okay yeah yeah
how do you know like um like I mean we
have the same challenge like I think I
my theory about it is that you get an
editorial instinct by just doing it like
pattern recognition by time you know the
stupid 10,000 hours whatever rule you
get enough so it's not so many data
points but you just you get so good at
what you do because you've been doing it
for a while but how do you like know
otherwise like that you know it's
working this I always get this question
I never know how to answer it kind of
develop this weird instinct that you
can't even explain it to the other
people who are asking you why you made a
decision you're like I just know that if
I phrase it this way or if I use this
subject line in an email that it's going
to get more intrinsic interest than it
totally agree I mean I think that's why
you like the more results you have under
your belt like if you're doing your own
content effort the better because
otherwise people get so caught up in
these abstract discussions and they're
debating that their strategy that
they're not actually just figuring out
what works that goes to your point
earlier about like just sort of having
enough of those points yeah and also
there's content all over the internet
like you don't have to reinvent the
wheel every time which is something that
I was like dude like New York Times
knows how to write a headline yeah but
so how do you guys measure effectiveness
yeah I mean I'll echo everything that
sonal said in terms of you know page
views it's nice to have as a guideline
time on page very important to us we
like seeing where people have dropped
off from a scrolling perspective you
know what could we have done better
about a Segway or a turn in the piece
the other things that I'll mention is
we're really
pay a lot of attention to social sharing
yeah like we actually have the counts
listed and that's been a feature that's
been very important for us to maintain
for the social proof quality for readers
but also for us to see you know did
people find this so valuable that they
felt compelled to share it with their
community that's the type of feedback
that is extremely valuable for us in our
motivation for why we create this
content to begin with and we even have
some mechanisms set up on slack where if
anyone that has over 10,000 followers
tweets about a piece of our content we
get an alert so that we can keep tabs on
how many influencers in this space are
engaging with and sharing I verbatim
think that's exactly the right way to
think about it and the way social is
important and I think people tend to
think social in terms of you know social
media sharing as this like marketing
word but actually what you care about is
that it's creating conversations around
your content and as a writer editor a
strategist whoever whatever your job is
you care about that conversation and
where it's going where people and
there's opportunities and some of the
misunderstandings the disagreements it's
also I think the other key about it is
that what you said about influencers
like 10,000 more than 10,000 I like to
look at the ratio of how many followers
to follow ease they have because
sometimes there are some influencers
that are just really focused and how
often they tweet so they don't have as
many followers but they're very very
influential because they have these
multiplicative sort of cascading effects
that their followers have 10,000
followers and a hundred thousand
followers and it multiplies and Cascades
and so I like to look at that
differential I do think I love that you
guys have a slack mechanism we dump
everything into slack yeah however it
mentions and it's kind of its kind of a
pain because you can't you also get
these trolls these random people like
you know randomly emailing you you know
for no reason they're not as always it's
just a tag you're not even assignment
relevant to the firm and if there's not
there's no relevance of just randomly
tagging random companies and so you have
no way of filtering that but I do think
that helps so how do you guys connect
with those influencer type folks I know
you like you kind of have a focused
effort there is that just by inviting
them on the podcast is that by
retweeting them like how do you get
connected that's a good question I mean
I think in our case and I want to give
huge credit to the bigger picture at our
firm which is that the content
operations sits in this broader
marketing group run by Margot when
Walker's who's my boss and she's really
the driver behind building the brand
remember a 16z so I will say that we had
this context of this existing brand of
influence that definitely helps and we
did not have a fully you know
operational content effort in place like
there were definitely individual blog
posts and blogs and Ben had his blog and
individual folks had their blogs so we
did we did put it into her more of a
strategy a cohesive strategy when I
joined and changed our focus on what we
do for content so to get to your point
about the influencer they have like a
whole network of relationships you know
both as a firm because the model is
around a network of networks like it's a
really network based model as and the
networks are everything from you know
media networks - you know fortune 500
and global 2000 like different operating
heads like manage each of those and so
not to give too much detail and a 16z
but that is the context in which we
operate so I think in our case it might
be a little different in terms of how we
engage those influencers yeah well cuz
these like you know if I look through
all the questions people sent in more
often than not they seem to be from our
early stage founders right so they're
looking for basically like the effective
dose you know like I'm going to like
find an influencer like how many do I
need who should I go for like what do
you guys recommend when you're just
getting started like I think not being
shy to reach out to folks like if you
see that someone is interested in what
you're doing don't let that opportunity
go by so whenever we see someone who
might not be in our community already or
who we might not know tweet about us we
will reach out and just be like hey
how's it going
and there's a few other things that
first round that they can also engage
with you know our events our mentorship
programs and so part of why we focus so
much on content is being able to feed
really extraordinary people into those
programs as well exact so we really try
to not let those opportunities pass us
by yeah I'm gonna share a trick that I
love which is it goes steal it steals
the idea that Kevin Kelley talked about
a lot which is like the whole you know
10,000 1,000 true fans you really want
sort of their true fans and you can
in every industry figure out who those
true fans are like I used to keep these
lists and private lists on Twitter of
different verticals that I was
interested when I was at Wired like it
could be machine learning at the time or
it could be developer influencers or it
could be you know I'm really personally
into maps and map making so I had a
whole list of all the people who are
really geeks about math I love that and
so you can just find all those people by
having those lists so first of all I
think even culling and putting together
a really good list is the first place to
start but my friend Dan Wang who I think
you know oh gosh he's so talented he's
so talented young great writer very
talented and one of the things that he
told me is that early on he sort of got
the attention of one influencer who's
Tyler Cohen and his strategy in his head
sort of became is this a piece a piece
that I'm writing that Tyler will pay
attention to and read and he only
targeted in his head that I'm gonna get
Tyler to read everything that I write
and sure enough
Tyler reads everything he writes shares
it and it's kind of created this amazing
thing and so yeah I mean it totally
makes sense right you just like build up
that fan of available pieces yeah yeah
it's something we need to get better
with oh I see mm-hmm yeah I mean um
we're not very interactive on our
Twitter either away yeah honestly
bluntly I you know we use our Twitter
feed as more of just like updates and
and sharing because there is enough
other people in our firm who tweet and
share so we don't need to be doing as
much of that under our account but we
feel very similarly that it's more of a
broadcast platform yeah yeah which I
think it's fine as long as you admit
that to yourself I think a lot of people
kid themselves into thinking like oh
we're gonna interact with our community
and grow it this way and that way and I
actually think that's a real mistake
because then you don't prioritize or
know where to prioritize your effort
because every content resource every
content operation by definition is
resource constrained because there's
always more you can do you know we were
just talking about this it's it's the
number one thing is that you really have
to be like this is what we're going to
be very good at exactly but I think you
guys nailed it like I love I when I
walked into a 16z I walked in like I
love what first round is doing with
their deeply reported well like produced
in a very like highly produced in the
sense of it's not just like some
just puts up a post and then there's no
no design no editing nothing like
there's clearly a process behind it it's
I think that's amazing find out what you
do really well and it hits for you same
with you in podcast I mean you pretty
much are the audio game in town the
whole ecosystem honestly it's it's best
part about that is that you know a
partner I think it was Chris Dixon had
originally said let's do podcasts and of
course like you know you can do it as an
experiment but then it can go nowhere
and in our case what we realized very
early on was you know we don't have to
actually only do podcast with our folks
which is great we love our folks but we
can also because I missed editing my
folks at Wired like the outside experts
and I used to also be the book excerpt
editor so I also missed having all these
book galleys that I'd get and no way to
do anything with them and because our
whole philosophy is this like network we
have and these collective of voices not
like a single point of view why wouldn't
we bring all those voices on and that
was sort of what created the podcast
like flywheel that sort of like a lot
more voices and their audiences cuz
you're right because then in the
beginning I had to put like beg book
publishers to get on our yeah all the
time
they're going but now it's like they're
like we get hit with too many pitches I
got even if we say no to most it's great
this is important to keep in mind right
because like first round andreessen
horowitz
are like mega brands right and so
someone who's just getting started has
to think about yeah like same with YC
like the podcasts like is basically just
getting going yeah and it takes time to
build that up it does and you don't have
to do everything so that that's the
question I want to get to so Twitter
account learn educate discover ask two
questions first question is which medium
are you most excited about the second
question is how do you choose a medium
so you can kind of answer those in
whatever order sure yeah this was a big
deal for us at the very beginning we
knew we wanted to do content marketing
we weren't sure what format was going to
resonate the most at the time doing
long-form was not the immediately
obvious thing to do no one hates it I
know right yeah most tech reporting also
is very snackable very short
it was kind of a double theory of what
is it that our audience really wants
like what is something that our ideal
reader needs and doesn't get in the
course of their daily lives and our
answer that was access to people who are
extremely skilled in this particular
area who are willing to share their
advice yeah and the best way to do that
was going to be in text and we didn't
want to offer just obvious advice we
wanted to offer a very full
counterintuitive detailed almost manual
like advice so we came up with this
guiding Northstar that we haven't
accomplished but it does help me in my
everyday work that we want to be The New
Yorker meets the Harvard Business Review
like can you tell beautiful literary
stories about people that also provide
tactical advice that can be applied
immediately and that's a bar that we
will continue to strive for in
everything that we write so I'm still
really excited about the power of text
we might branch out into other things
but for now yeah and to your point I
think focus is like one of the most
important things when it comes to
content I agree and I think people
actually don't know where to begin with
this and I think what you said about
having a guiding North Star is critical
because the number one thing whenever
founders or folks ask me for content
console-like you know how do we get
started I always ask them like why what
are you trying to do and I know that
sounds again so obvious but you'd be
shocked at how people sort of almost
feel like they're automatically
executing some PlayBook without actually
pausing to ask that and even frankly for
media brands when I think of which ones
are more successful versus not
successful out there if you ask people
within that company what's your guiding
started to steal your phrase and my in
my world I used to have this kind of
rule of thumb that if you can actually
Ben distill it to two words it works
really well so when I was at Xerox PARC
where I did content and community for a
long time first the two words were
entrepreneurial scientists when I was at
Wired the two words were informed
optimism which is from Chris Anderson
and we have two words for a six in see
also which I don't even know if I'm
allowed to shares I won't share them but
the idea is that you have a lens that
then lets you choose what to do and it
makes you it plays out at every level so
to answer your question about the best
format I think it actually begins the
best what's the best why are we doing
this what's the idea behind it that's
dry
it how are we gonna attack it because I
think sourcing ideas is not the hard
part for most people it's executing on
them and then having that lens to your
point your gut you guys are sort of The
New Yorker meets Harvard Business Review
we have a lens to then it allows you
then to then at a very specific level go
edit the piece including deciding what
format it'll fit but more importantly it
lets you decide what you're gonna kill
because a lot of people don't realize it
really good content is like 80 percent
about killing crap it's about choices
yeah and knowing that you can't make all
of them you can't you have to focus and
choose exactly and so on the formatting
side we do everything bluntly which I
would not advise everyone to do but I
think that in our case like you know
text you're right like I think text is
always gonna be there it's universal so
text is huge voice is great the key
about voice is that you can convey a lot
more nuance and trickier discussions in
a way that you can't in text 104 site
it's so much fun the trade-off however
is that people don't screenshot and
share like when you share a piece it
travels on Twitter and you see people
taking your full quotes and your
excerpts or in our case like we'll see
like specific snippets that doesn't
always happen with voice and so there is
a limitation on that front the rule for
us is thinking about it's not an
arbitrary thing like it's actually
really what medium best fits the way
what we're trying to tell but yet to
figure out what you're trying to tell
and then the best medium for it and I
don't think people should dismiss things
like listicles like we do a ton of those
16 things 16 metrics they think it's
really the quality of the content are
you saying things that are new knowledge
that are really inspiring of new
conversation especially that's all it is
is it good content period yep and you
have to have a very high bar for that
yes and so if a startup approaches one
of you guys and they haven't figured out
what they're going for like what are you
advising them on the medium like are you
asking them you know what are your
customers looking for and what do you
say I will just say that where it starts
for when I am advising some startups in
our portfolio about how they can produce
things that their audience is going to
gravitate to it usually starts with what
do those audience members want to
accomplish in their own
yeah and that may or may not be related
to what the product or the company
actually does but if they can somehow
provide content that helps people get to
that end goal for themselves then
they're going to reap the halo effect of
being able to be that helpful
so producing high utility stuff is what
I sort of my go-to recommendation yeah I
totally agree with you and I think it's
to your point there's a match between
what the audience wants and how they
want to get it I used to always ask
people like what are like the top three
things that your audience reads like and
then that kind of serves as a model like
okay so they're a New York Times reader
or they're a Harvard Business Review
reader or they actually read blogs
they're developers they read github you
know where they leave on lives right are
they on Twitter all day scrolling
through moments or they don't even ever
use Twitter and they only you know write
on pay plug we've had startups that have
customers especially in government where
they're conveying information only on
paper like in folders that are being
passed around department a department
then you have to actually think about
like that's your audience to your point
how do you find that out like this is a
push on our go wall ask this question
like okay so say you have some ideas but
how do you actually figure out what your
customers your clients where are they
hanging out what are they reading so a
couple things that we've done and some
of them just recently is we hold founder
listening sessions where we'll have a
founder come in and talk to our entire
team and about their experience and
where are the gaps and what they need to
succeed what are they getting from maybe
other firms or other advisors what do
they really love about what they're
getting from first round and a lot of
stuff surfaces from those in terms of
like topics they feel have been left
uncovered from all the resources they
have at their disposal so there's that
and then we're also really fortunate to
have a really robust intranet at first
round that connects a lot of our
companies together so they can ask and
answer each other questions it's the
team that builds that is just they're
incredible and I benefit a lot from it
because I get to see which questions
appear over and over and over again or
we give people the option to follow a
question so you'll see a question get
asked and be followed by a tremendous
number of people but there won't be a
lot of satisfying
answers that come up and that's really
ripe opportunity for us to then go find
an answer yeah that's so great
I come from an ethnographic background
you know where you think a lot about it
was started off in education in the
world of Education where you'd learn by
observing so also listening and learning
is the same kind of philosophy but you'd
actually really go kind of physically in
person almost practically like an
embedded journalist if you think about
it and I think one of the keys and I
counsel companies to do this all the
time when they think about content
strategy is it sounds again so cliche
and obvious but it's actually really
true and people don't do it which is
really talking to everybody you can to
get like become first like a complete
funnel for bringing as many info sources
as you can talk to your sales if you're
doing it for customer marketing purposes
talk to the people on the ground talk to
the customers talk to whoever you can
and if you can't talk because you often
can't like you know waste people's time
you can listen in and you can also ask
people for recordings like I've asked
our folks like okay like we can't listen
to every single conversation but we can
listen into this one or we can attend
this you know this companies coming in
to get a briefing I want to listen in
because I really want to hear what's top
of mind for the CTO this top 500 fortune
500 company to really get how they're
thinking about AI in practice for
example and then obviously you have a
whole network of sources or resources
outside your firm and outside your
borders and that's people who are
watching the space are interested in the
space and there's so many opportunities
in this especially if you live in an
environment or a city where there's a
lot of events conferences I know I kind
of agree like you should not waste too
much time at conferences in general but
you can be very targeted and focused
about picking one or two events in a
year that are really gonna maximize your
info flow and I really think about it as
sitting at the center of this web of
information and making sure that you're
using all of it to figure out what's
happening and it won't directly tie in
it doesn't map neatly into it turns into
a piece but it gives you this sort of
info scent and this sort of context that
when you do go into figuring out a piece
or getting a pitch or proposing an idea
that you then know how to attack it
because you know what everyone else is
saying and what's working what's not
working and then you can do a way better
job that
get attention versus the 20 other things
that people wrote like the hot takes
approach yeah I think that that's
amazing advice but that's like really
people should definitely follow that I
will also say that like maybe
piggybacking on that a little bit I've
heard about this concept a little bit
more recently about customer advisory
boards where startups can basically
recruit an informal early customer base
that is bought into giving them feedback
and you know you maybe have like a taco
and margarita night like once a quarter
and you have the opportunity to really
talk to them about what it is that they
need and I think using that and maybe
it's the people that you meet at these
events that you're talking about and
using that type of thing to listen in
and see about bubbles to the surf and to
your point like you guys do events we do
events they are like that physical touch
point to get a lot of that type of
because in conversation people start
bandying things back and forth you end
up somewhere that you never thought you
would totally and yeah it's very organic
feeling it is very organic and in fact
you have to have a lot of patience for
it because I even I might not seem this
way and this is why I love podcasting
I'm actually quite introverted I do not
like socialising email do you want to
meet and I'm like no I don't want to
meet I want to edit leave me alone
like cocktail parties are sometimes not
my jam like I'll go I have an hour limit
like I can go for an hour than I'm done
and the last time I think I met you I
think I hang out for an hour and I go
I've been here for an hour I really
relate to and I think the thing is
though that you do have to let yourself
have these sort of serendipitous
conversations but you're always
listening like always
what does that joke that people say
always be selling like in the content
world I think it's really always be
listening totally always have to hear
because otherwise you don't get good
ideas and it was always when I was at
Wired I did do these sort of quarterly
lunches with like developer influencers
to kind of get a sense of what was
bubbling up next cool you know like open
source communities because there is this
idea that the most interesting things
happen in forums like Reddit and other
places cuz to us it was true by the time
I hit the New York Times it's like we're
never gonna do a piece on me and I have
the same philosophy here too because we
want to be starting the conversation
and if we're not starting the
conversation then we want to be the one
adding a lot of really good value to the
conversation what we don't want to do is
being in the middle where it's noisy and
no one's listening to each other and you
have no point in adding any value and a
lot of people in their content efforts
unfortunately get stuck in that dead
zone in the middle
totally definitely I think there are all
of these channels where they're giant
open areas where you can just win and
that's what I'm always about like yeah
and like YouTube is one of them like you
can just like they're all these
softballs out there that you can just
hit yeah and we pay a lot of attention
on the technical side like tracking
inbound stuff yeah we like log search
queries on our blog so like we know what
people are looking for and you can do
stuff that way you can see what pages
people are coming in from and then you
just have to hang out there and that's
like the the ArtScience divide where you
just have to be part of the community
I'm glad you said that it's art science
divided because that is I think the
other best piece of advice is that
people you're so smart to track all
those queries and be aware of them you
have those questions follow this
questions see where the opportunities
are I think when people take it too far
it becomes crowdsourcing editorial which
is the worst thing ever which I think
you have to have a point of view which I
don't need like an editor-in-chief a
de-facto editor-in-chief and every
content effort to sort of drive that
point of view even if it's taking input
it's not saying like it's my way or the
highway you take inputs from everybody
but you can't have like this model which
I have seen a lot of people do because
to your point they're trying to figure
out and get started so you empathize
where it's sort of like crowdsourcing
everything and then you kind of don't
know what the point is
you do I think you lose or you limit
your creativity if you make your content
super data-driven I'm like oh well I've
heard from this number of people now
that they want us to write about this
exactly then you're totally sacrificing
your ability to write the unexpected
thing that people didn't know they want
exactly what people already know versus
what you don't know that they don't know
our biggest hit and my favorite piece
because I know someone has that oh yeah
was our WeChat piece you know it's
what's that favorites are all your
babies are all blah blah mommy so it's
awesome we were kids like I love my
thumb I love my pointer finger I love
all my kids equally but you're all
different and now I'm like I think my
little brother was her favorite
like we chats like one of my our piece
that we did um Connie Chan who's like
our China expert wrote this amazing deep
dive on WeChat but the thing is it was
three months of back-and-forth and
really talking through like what are the
big idea is finding what the big idea
was and thinking through deeply the
approach we wanted to take we took a
very ethnic graphic approach to telling
that narrative and it got chosen I was
this is probably my one of my happiest
moments um in the New York Times David
Brooks does his annual Sydney awards and
it was chosen in the 2015 Sydney awards
as one of the best pieces of long-form
writing and the best part is it was the
first time an on media outlet had been
included in it yeah and so they actually
were had to say like on the end recent
horowitz website but I'm not telling
that story just like brag I'm telling
that story because there's a point and
the point is that nobody from the get-go
if we had crowdsource this idea would
have ever said it made any sense it was
like 5,000 words long I was actually
gonna cared to put it out cuz people
were saying she split it in two and I'm
like nope I'm doing it this way and
here's why and I know it and I had a gut
in my bones that this is the right way
to do it and Kanye gave me a ton of
trust as we collaborated as writer and
editor and it boom it just had this so
slow swell and let it keep still coming
back it's amazing that's awesome and I
what I also really love about that story
is just you mentioning how much
investment in time and effort that
required that one of these stories it is
like a three month effort sometimes and
that's totally invisible I think to a
lot of people yeah especially those
getting started with content who expect
it to be a little bit lighter lift or
more instantaneous that it really takes
a lot if you don't mind asking like
what's the average production time for
one of your pieces on a regular basis it
takes a while it's definitely at the
very shortest to several week process
because we don't just do an interview we
have a prep conversation with the person
so that we're on the same page everyone
knows what to anticipate we've teased
out a topic we feel really strongly
about so then there's the interview and
then it does take a significant number
of hours just to assemble a conversation
into a cogent argument yeah this is
where I think the advice I mean a
gun sounds you know like something that
people talk about content marking this
is were the editorial calendar is so key
because you will always have like 10 to
15 to 20 in our case sometimes hundreds
of balls in the air and sadly and at a
certain point some you're putting
through production in a very systematic
way others you're actually just showing
on the back burner because the time
isn't right and then all of a sudden
something happens and you're like this
is the time to start talking about that
topic and you can actually push that
forward and I think that's where it
helps a lot to make those trade-offs to
sort of balance that out I think that's
also pro tip for getting started that
was one Zack on Twitter asked the
question like how do you get started
doing inbound so basically like content
yeah having more than one ball in the
air is actually a really good thing
have you uh have you read the war of art
yeah he talks about the resistance the
resistance and he also talks about
starting your book before you finished
the current one and so like that that's
what I found with a lot of even personal
creative projects where you're like oh
man we're done and that kills you for
the other stuff because you have nothing
going and then you take a month and like
one of the unfortunate things you do
have to publish fairly off you do have
not every day right it's like being on a
conveyor belt yeah in a lot of senses
where it's like okay well I have to be
thinking about the ones back here even
though this one is coming to fruition
you know exactly no I totally totally
agree and this is why I think the
editorial calendar is not just a
planning mechanism but I'm gonna steal a
concept from Robin Sloane I love this
idea of stock versus flow and content
because what happens is you get so
caught up on that conveyor about
sometimes you end up getting in reactive
mode that you actually forget to go into
proactive mode about what are the
stories we're trying to tell and why
because sometimes you're too busy
reacting and the ideas you're getting or
they're urgencies or something if it's a
startup sometimes a sales team is saying
we need more stuff on this you're not
actually doing like a divide like 70/30
or whatever percentage works for you to
figure out how to make sure you do the
big ideas or the big things you're
trying to push forward and I do think
having an editorial calendar and the
right tools to kind of balance all this
help you make those things that you then
know like to your point you're not done
and then oh crap what comes next
totally or also how do you think about
having sort of the data
quote flow and then having those big
stock like pieces like the 3-month
WeChat project or other things like that
especially when your so you're just
getting started you don't really know
what you're gonna do if you bite off
something that's crazy you won't have
the energy to like do other stuff as
soon it like you know if we did an
animated version of the podcast that was
like an hour-long animated video and we
did one and it was great
like we wouldn't be able to do anything
else right I'm so glad you said that
everybody totally miss underestimates
how important creative energy is and I
just think that's so key like you have
to have the energy down to planning your
day like if you know you're an editor or
writer that needs the morning then don't
have meetings in the morning and the
other things when you work in a company
you have a lot of freaking meetings oh
my gosh and people coming up to your
desk asking questions slack is one of
the biggest problems in my life I love
slack the product but when I'm trying to
write a piece yeah yeah yeah but just
the realities of the modern office and
the open floor plan very difficult it is
but it was a hard hard transition when I
left wired and came day 16 see and I was
like oh my god I can't do meetings and
at one point I literally threw my hands
up and sort of was like we don't need to
have this meeting but if we do can only
do it on these days and then blocking
off the time because otherwise what
happens is you have quote the meeting
stuff and then the creative 24/7 and not
only is it bad from a balanced
perspective cuz you're writing and
editing late to the night or early very
early in the morning the creative flow
is it's not the right thing for you're
setting up your success I actually love
a post that ycs Paul Graham wrote on
this a long time ago make your manager
schedule manager schedule everybody
knows great it is like a Bible for me I
send it to everybody because I actually
find that when you're in the tech
industry drawing parallels between
writing editing and creative with
developers people actually get it then
there's there is definitely like an
empathy that exists there
sure you have to say like when you even
talk about multiplying your effort like
the coordination costs increase oh okay
now I get it like you've got to help
people understand so it's a give I would
give people advice if you're talking to
a tech founder who doesn't have the
creative background then maybe do use
the analogy of developers to help you
you have to get into a flow station
there's 20 minutes at the very least of
dedicated this is the only thing that
I'm looking at and doing sort of time I
would say an hour yeah get away with it
at least it's hard to come by
yeah 20 minutes is too short I think too
many distractions and notifications do
you turn off notifications on you I do I
actually used this program called ohm
writer that now like total have you seen
that it totally like wipes out your
screen so that you can't see anything
else and it's just like a very crisp
piece of paper with writing down and
also if you have your headphones in the
faster you type the more rain sounds you
coordinated and I get into life is very
meditative I will opposite which is I
like a noisy environment for writing I
like likewise in the back no I like
being I don't like being in libraries I
like being in crowded noisy places but I
also really like 20 I like 200 tabs open
at any given time but to your point I
will not I will definitely have to put
aside notifications because that is the
most distracting thing when you're
trying to get work that's the worst you
know I'm totally like 6:00 a.m. Wi-Fi
turned off the other person I'm an early
morning person - on the editing yeah
middle of the day I don't get nearly as
much done
which is unfortunate yeah I'm tired by
the end of the day so I just feel like
I'm not as good like I'm I have to look
at it with fresh eyes in the morning
yeah yeah but it's not just physical
energy but creative energy is like this
whole other feeling yes and I'm glad
we're talking about it because it almost
seems fluffy on the surface but if you
actually are working in a company you
have to think about it and manage it
very creatively and cleverly I mean it's
super valuable time right like if you're
a knowledge worker it's really about
like getting a couple good hours and
every day and if you just break it up
with all like random email nonsense that
you like you don't get to you don't get
even like two good hours no but the
problem is that the even knowledge
workers have a meaning culture because
they have to do meetings to do their job
and for a lot of us we don't have to do
as many of those meetings unless they're
like listening and learning meetings or
whatnot so I do think we can actually
remove ourselves from a lot of those
meetings I mean literally I like doing
an audit like do I really need to be
here or does if conversely does your
content person really need to be here if
you're a founder right I think you end
up in a really nice place because we
have a somewhat work-from-home
culture here and what's great about
doing content is that people recognize
you is still productive even when you're
not in the office what you're doing
you're right because we actually have a
concrete product that is one thing I
love is that you kind of control the
output in that way yeah I'm very into it
all right so a couple questions from
Bridget Bradford I think Camille should
start this one what interview strategies
do you find most useful sure yeah so all
of our content is interview based which
has applied a very interesting
constraint and also has forced me to get
very good at this particular thing
because I only get an hour with most of
these people you only do an hour yeah
and I really I want them to know that
I'm treasuring their time so I try to
keep it like very much so like okay the
60 minutes but making sure people say
the most valuable thing they could
possibly say within that context is
really hard so the framework that I've
found to be the most helpful I
considered like a three-tier framework
the first being somebody's gonna throw
out just a response to your question
like maybe it'll be like kind of
high-level like let's say that I'm like
oh you know how do you manage your time
they'll be like well this is how I sort
of structure my calendar and then you
want to ask one question deeper which is
you know what is the specific thing that
you're doing which I love like you've
you've done that a few times in this
interview which is great so that then
they have to focus their think a little
bit more and then a third level being
give me an example of you actually doing
that in practice and the impact that it
made for you and just having people move
through that ends up giving me a lot
more fodder to work with at the end of
the day when I'm trying to piece it
together
I love I love that you have such a
structured way of doing that I love that
you guys do because we don't do written
interviews as much we do very very few
of them so a big difference in our
there we obviously do interviews and
podcast form mm-hmm and in our case what
we tell them is to think about you're
just having lunch with people like
you're sitting at a table and you're
talking about this idea and you're just
trying to get but the way I like to
describe it is that you're trying to
take people along with you on a journey
of understanding so they're coming along
with you so you're not being
condescending like talking down to them
like here's the thing you don't know
about right but you're also trying to
get them to like get why is it
interesting and why should they be into
what you're saying um the other thing
that we think a lot about when it comes
to the interviewing is and it's not like
a rule of thumb it's not quite as
structured it's just more like an
informal thing that we've learned but
definitions and terminology go a really
long way in our case because we're
talking a lot about new technologies and
new innovations and so you'd be
surprised at how people obviously don't
agree on definitions and so getting
people to ground themselves about what
they mean by something is a really great
starting point because a it grounds a
conversation which shared language but
then it takes people who are listening
or reading along on the same journey but
more importantly I love it because it
gives you more precision and that helps
differentiate which what everyone else
is doing because what tends to happen
especially in our world is that when
you're explaining innovation people have
this perception of this X sort of magic
realism that's magic that's happening
and so the more specific and precise the
definition the more you it's it's
demystifying that magic you're good
funding it in you're grounding it and
something that it's like okay here's
what it is I think analogies are super
useful we use a ton of analogies I'm
actually really obsessed with this do
you prep those beforehand never no never
for for the podcast like I walk in
because I want this mindset of sort of a
I'm listening to learn now my boss
called [ __ ] on me one day when I'm
like I walk and I don't prep and she's
like you prep all the time you read all
the time and I'm like okay I guess I
prep in that way so that is prep because
I think it's a mistake to also come in
and say like I'm just gonna act like a
newbie without knowing because you have
to know like sort of the general space
on the arc and the arguments oh yeah I
don't prep I kind of let it kind of see
where things go and sort of pick on
threads I run into that issue all the
time you do use it well it's just so
well yet the way I would answer that
like the name of the game is making
people feel comfortable yeah so like you
know I don't like to impose hard stop
times I definitely don't go less than a
half an hour it's like almost always an
hour but you know the YC interviews at
fun hacker news very frequently and on
one hand we're trying to make content
for you know people who are just getting
into this but on the other hand it ends
up on Hacker News doesn't know what he's
talking about I really think there's a
toxic culture there and that is
frustrating and I agree like I I get
people like I get all kinds of comments
like I get everything from don't costs
which I get a lot too and I almost feel
like are they saying this to the men but
hey that's a separate thing and then I
get all kinds of other stuff you know
one of the some of the tricks that we've
learned like unfortunately for better or
worse especially when it comes to voice
medium you do have to interrupt because
people can't listen to one voice for a
very long time so you have to kind of
force yourself to do that some of the
other things that we do is try to break
the script this is especially true a
book up book authors that come on our
podcast because a they're doing they're
going on everyone's podcast so we're not
getting them exclusively using
boilerplate language they're just throw
into their book and they've been on this
book tour that they're almost repeating
the same story so you have to break that
so I would say so
opposite actually where I'm trying to
break their comfort zone because
otherwise they're gonna say the same
[ __ ] they sent and every other podcast
about that book so and we did you've all
her ariane sapiens we just had to take a
very different tack on his conversation
because it was he's such an interesting
guy but he's also doing like 20 other
podcasts i I would encourage people if
you're doing podcasts to like slide into
the podcast because there I've been in
other rooms where you're having an
awesome conversation you're just hanging
out and then all of a sudden they're
like okay start the podcast and like
someone's Yanks the air out of the room
and every day
my name is Craig oh my god this is such
a true fact and one of the things we do
is we start the recorder before they
even enter and we don't turn it off
until they leave and of course we're not
putting things on without their
permission but you're absolutely right
that's exactly what happens a minute
yous like okay we're starting it's like
there's a sudden shift of stiffness that
just happens and it kind of warms up
energy wise and you have to think about
this because the key and I was telling
our folks and and at a six and zi2 when
we're working on editing and how to
think about it is you have like five
levers you have energy you have content
you have expertise you have examples you
have personal narratives and stories and
you have to pull them at different
points at different weights and if one
is weak like there's not a really good
energy then you really got to amp up the
other lever if the energy is great you
can kind of get away with not having a
very nice I love beautiful linear
narrative or script because you don't
have conversation like that but you have
to have some combination of what at
least three of them and we have two
examples combination it doesn't have to
be three it can be one only yeah but it
has to be some combination of them in
some way that's super helpful yeah it's
just hard honestly it's not it's like
hard-earned learned expertise really
more that's the thing it's just like
volume and you can't be super Precious
about your stuff you know I've put out
podcasts I'm like ah this one's gonna be
cool yeah nothing and then others where
we're like oh this is gonna be fine and
it does great and so yeah I don't know I
think you can't let yourself be deflated
like I've definitely had instances where
I was so excited about something and
then it hardly got as many views is
something else that was totally out of
the blue and you just can't let yourself
lose your momentum over that really
can't and I know like it's different for
editors and writers because one could
argue that we don't have the same skin
in the game sure because someone could
say well if it's my byline then it's
like a different thing in your case you
are the byline so it's a different skin
in the game and that is that there is
some truth to that I'm not gonna deny it
but you're right like you have to have
this attitude that you put the product
on and you out and you move on yeah and
the best fun parts is when that
something's evergreen and it keeps
popping up over and over again I love
that happens great yeah that's yeah you
have to have some pieces that you might
have done like three years ago and
you're first started that are still
surfacing which are
your best hits like that definitely yeah
likewise and it's always fun to see that
on Twitter and then you see a whole new
conversation bloom around like that yeah
that's cool
that by the way another one of our
metrics of successes is it evergreen and
I don't mean like a static library
because that's really boring but is it
something that it's just because we're
not a media outlet there's plenty of
wonderful media outlets out there we're
trying to do what other people aren't
doing or covering in a way that other
people aren't covering it and so given
that you have to think very carefully
about what value you're adding to the
conversation and sometimes news can
serve as a time hook a timing hook but
it's not the driver to write or do a
piece it's too reactive otherwise they
don't work and understand that when I
travel so much advice or insight that
continues to be really relevant so your
guys's case it's at Universal yeah or
the technologies that you've talked
about in the past they are now coming
home to roost it's very interesting yeah
you're right although I will say that I
think advice has more staying power for
sure because I think some of the tech
stuff some in some spaces it moves
almost too quickly like if you're
talking about say crypto or I cos then
it does with another topic where you can
kind of get away with something more and
by the way my advice for people when
they are doing content in those efforts
is to think very carefully about where
you are in the cycle of that particular
narrative and if it is early days you
don't have to be the first and then be
the one who's adding a lot of value
thoughtfully but then you're gonna have
to really have the discipline to
actually hold yourself back and wait
because there's this tendency when
people are excited to be like oh but I
want it I want to add in and it's like
great hold it wait till we have enough
thoughtful things to add and if we don't
don't you have nothing to say having
that discipline is hard it's hard it's
really hard yeah I like it goes back to
that thing about killing it's about as
much what you choose not to do versus
what you choose to do always
yeah well it's especially hard when you
see the spikes around a trend right like
so we'll put out some crypto thing and
you know it'll get like 2 3 4 X what a
normal poster should we just only do
crypto stuff one of my earliest posts
was about the virtues of holacracy so
and how to implement this at your own
company and it's still there on the site
there staring at me
and there are a lot of other valuable
gems in that piece but that it's in the
title cool all right we have a few more
questions so maybe actually this is
another one for Camille so Darren Alpert
asks how do you leverage customer
stories in your marketing your content
yeah that's an interesting one for us
because it's not necessarily hitting
exactly what he's probably getting at
because our customers are somewhat
non-traditional like our customers in
our conception are happy founders who
are getting all of the resources they
need to succeed in this particular area
and so essentially the stories that we
do write are all customer stories
because we're saying look at these other
extremely talented ambitious people who
have succeeded you can use these same
methods and tools to do the same so
really the way that we're hoping to do
that is to show by example that there
are successful paths through this
journey of being an entrepreneur and
hoping that enough people out there are
reading who are at aspiring toward this
that they're going to think of first
round when they start that journey yeah
we same case we don't have the type of
customer stories that you're talking
about or that this person is probably
talking about I think that's more like
the classic marketing model I will give
one piece of advice from the editorial
point of view which is always think
about how you can tell the narrative in
a non literal way because what marketers
tend to do and it's not a bad thing it
makes you very good at your job for
marketing or you know PR communications
or other skills as you're thinking very
carefully about who are the experts you
can put with the with a person who are
the what's the right you know what's a
fit from the topic to the speaker to the
voice but when you're actually doing
editorial you want to take a twist on
that you don't want to be so literal
where it's like okay because if it's
gonna be literal then just make a case
study and you can do it that way then
and target it the people that exactly
and to be what it is exactly but don't
masquerade it as something that's not
editorial or if you're going to then
make it editorial like then ask yourself
like okay how do wait up level at a
notch how do I take a different angle on
it or how do I make it more fresh so
it's different than what everyone else
is saying in the same way because that's
a bite that I've had for many years and
many companies when you've been in
content
and it's like when I was at Xerox PARC
you know a Xerox it was a big yeah
company like there was a lot of
back-and-forth around some of this stuff
and you have to take a little bit of a
fresh twist I would say just to add on
to that that I tell a lot of our
founders who are just starting to
explore content that in order for it to
really resonate it needs to be either
really useful or really emotional yes
and by emotional it has to be like I'm
crying I have to send this to my best
friend right now which is like really
hard to do and like you're not going to
be able to nail that most of the time so
useful as much easier so really
over-indexing on I I'm so glad you said
that and I would add one thing to that
so because I think people people who are
listening to this or entrepreneurs and
want to do their own content will that
will benefit from that being useful and
then being a resource like because it
kind of the same thing but they're
slightly different and I think this goes
another easy way to get started back to
an earlier question which is we always
counsel people this to think about data
and data narratives as a great place to
start it's a it's instant
differentiation because you have data
that uniquely no one else does and that
makes you forces you to make sure you're
having different things that you're
saying be it's at the core of what your
business is if your business is data
center which frankly every day business
seems to be a tech business seems to be
this days and then see it does influence
how you might hire because the question
then becomes do you start with the data
scientist did you start with the data
type of journalist the ideal is to find
someone who has the skill to find a
story but who can also understand the
data but I think data is a huge untapped
opportunity for a lot of content
marketers at startups and that's not
being used nearly enough as it should be
and people do it really well yeah I mean
there are all these templates you can
basically follow for that like I don't
have to be you know Stephen King to like
write a great blog sweet data and use a
visual even yeah that many words in it
you can just show through the visuals
like what the folks at Price anomic sirs
are doing it blows my mind so there's a
lot to borrow from that I think NAM
exciting okay keep it did an amazing job
mix and doing a lot of great stuff in
this area I love that team yeah
my favorite people yes but there's a lot
of yeah I agree there's a lot to be done
they're not when I was an op-ed editor
mhm I used to always tell people too
because the other big thing I care about
is write or topic fit and that's the
authenticity of the person that this
matters a lot for our stuff cuz it's
first-person yeah you care very much is
this the right person for this topic and
this is not a credential as thing you
don't have to have a degree in AI to do
a piece on AI but it better then damn
well be earned expertise or you've spent
a [ __ ] ton of time looking at a ton of
data or you have some insight that no
one else has and then it's interesting
so otherwise it doesn't have this sort
of authority and voice that it needs
doesn't even have like the energy of the
authentic curiosity which yeah the New
York is you can convey that authentic
curiosity because you do do an amazing
job of getting the voice of the people
you're interviewing into the pieces but
you're the ones still writing them yeah
hoping to convey how important it is to
this person and being yellow chittim
utley curious about how they got to
where they've got to be so curious cuz
otherwise people I think have a real
[ __ ] radar that this is just someone
trying to like make a name for
themselves I used to get pitches like
you know here's how to be a CEO blank
and I'm like but you've never been a CEO
yeah about that and if you do want to
write about it then go interview 100
CEOs and get me data that can then give
you that knit and then play that
narrative back yeah it's the same kind
of thing well that's going into like the
one pitfall that I wanted to bring up
here and yeah oh my god don't turn it
into a sales pitch yeah and like this is
what we see companies do it all the time
like oh all right we're gonna get into
content we're gonna do profiles of our
users and they like have five questions
and each answer is like two sentences
long with like no insight and then
they're like boom going for this hard
sell no one get like well uncared both
the person you interviewed doesn't care
they're embarrassed because they're in
an ad and your readers your users don't
care at all either because there's no
insight here so that would be the one
thing that I would just avoid at all
cause I think you have to be really
delicate about that that like people can
sniff out advertorial stuff and even if
you feel like they that you're doing a
really good job masking it yeah
um it's it's tough I would also say that
some of the bests and smartest thinkers
anyone know they're doing it yeah they
just are so into what they're doing that
sometimes it just don't even realize it
and so all sometimes be like you know
you just sort of said that like it's an
ad for the product but like pretend like
you don't have to even say the name of
the company or what you do like how
would you then explain this the big
picture why does this matter
it just go back to that whole plastic
thing of starting with why yeah why why
do I care why should you care why does
someone why should someone else who has
no idea what it is care and just keep
pushing that why does it matter and keep
pushing that again it seems again so
obvious because it's like what we do all
the time but right that is what it's
about is probing for that and making
sure of that do you think yes so much of
the content is set up to be like we're
going to illuminate a problem that is
going to be solved by our product yes
and so if you feel like you're running
into that wall I would really urge
anyone out there to think about all the
problems that are not that problem yeah
your users have and what can you do to
answer those problem oh my god I'm so
glad you said that because that used to
be my my number one pitch I'd get when I
was at Wired yeah every pitch was an
op-ed masquerading right they didn't
even talk about their product but the
solution was their product right and
it's if they don't say it no they were
like it's a big but if you took it out
of three levels and you said like okay
take it up and level then another level
they think of it as like adjacent
circles like here's your product here's
the ideas in that space and now here's
the big industry and there's somewhere
in that space between big industry and
the product somewhere in there is an
interesting idea
it's an idea to kill yeah I think it's
the best of guys yeah I know right yeah
it's just not obvious like what doesn't
make it but a ton of stuff doesn't make
it that's right that's why I want it
that's why I want to keep pushing this
because people outside will never know
and it's also knowing that like when
you've already told a story one to say
one with a lot of these people are just
like alright we're just gonna do it
again do it again like we're on and
we're on the treadmill we're going and
like
to a certain extent yes like we get it
with YC we're like we wrote this post
two years ago like this is here but then
you know we don't publish it every month
yeah and so like something we keep
imposing is key yeah yeah yeah okay cool
so we have a few more
another one from Bridget how do you see
content marketing evolving I'm an avid
whatsapp user and because I have an
extended relative network in India and
I've been using whatsapp for ages and
one of the things that I love is that
there's this new form of like messaging
native content that I actually think we
think of content as showing up in in
Twitter and in text and in voice of
course I love voice that's the thing
that I care about is about video is
important clearly but I think there's
actually a huge opportunity in the
future and I don't know if we're ready
for it quite yet for like messaging
native content which is really inventing
it from scratch where you're not just
putting like in the olden days when
people used to put like a newspaper
image on the New York Times website and
that's there like you have to think
natively and in the messaging platforms
like how can content be shared because I
see what gets moved in my whatsapp group
so among my relatives yeah it's kind of
a fascinating questions I don't have a
thought on it but I have an open-ended
thing that this is an interesting area
to mean that in the future I this is
like years away probably I totally agree
that it's more thinking around how
content flows through social networks in
particular so one of things that I found
most interesting recently is long-form
newsletters
oh yes the traditional thinking has been
like do not write a long email like it's
the worst don't have multiple pieces of
content in an email but then I see
things like Lenny letter like we need to
do more Lenny letter like totally booked
like everything that people thought was
what was the way to do a email
newsletters and then Heaton Shaw who I'm
like a devotee of I think he's so
brilliant about content he has a
long-form newsletter that's gotten a lot
of traction yeah and I think that that's
related to your point that like email is
a much more personal messaging medium
and you're seeing content flow through
it more interestingly and it's going to
happen over text it's gonna happen over
Facebook like what is the way to carry
through I totally agree with you and I
love the thing about email because when
we you know you guys have a newsletter
we did a different type of newsletter
where we were just sharing what we're
reading but then a bunch of people start
doing the same thing so we were like mmm
now I got I mean I read all of those
like the newsletters that aggragate I
know and I love those but then I'm
actually
like I've said this before but I have
this favorite quote from Gilmore Girls
where Lorelai Gilmore goes like you know
you're gonna I'm in a zig and then
you're gonna see me coming and I'm gonna
zag and then I'm gonna zag again just to
keep you on your toes and I love that
line because that's how I think about
strategy like you have to change it up
and when everyone else is doing the same
thing I'm kind of almost so bored of it
now yeah I'm kind of like I don't want
to do them anymore we're gonna do
something different when you start
feeling that sea change internally it's
usually time yeah you get crowded but to
your point absolutely I do think that
people underestimate the power of email
yeah it's gonna stick around I don't
care what anyone says it's not going
away cuz it's personal like I am going
to engage with something in my inbox
probably if it actually lands in my
inbox crockery yeah well I think it's it
often just comes down to doing something
really well you know it's like if you're
the best podcast the best newsletter the
best whatever it's all good like I think
there's space for winners in like every
category I totally agree but when people
just do like a mediocre job of almost
everything you're like no I will add to
that though that it's always a
competition yeah and I don't mean this
and just being a competitive person but
more in the way that attention is a
competition in the media landscape and
everything is blended to bleed it
together like whether it's bled together
whether it's an email newsletter a
written piece a podcast your attention
is limited and so because of that you do
have to keep an edge and so if you don't
have it I don't think anyone can rest on
their laurels basically you know I can
say they've nailed this medium and then
they can just like hang out because
after a while there will be competition
it's like classic disruption it'll come
from unexpected corners and I mean I'm
kind of that kind of a person like
everything it's like what we were
talking about before like the injuries
in Horowitz podcast competes with cereal
like it's just not it's not like I have
a separate tech podcasting app I'm like
an entertainment it's all entertainment
right yeah and that listeners are not
like now is the portion of my time that
I devote to tech listen
thank you yeah I also tell startups this
to where it's like you are competing
with all of the storytelling that's
going on out there so tell some
interesting story exactly and which
again is another obvious thing but read
first what other people are writing
because you believe it or not there is
this hubris where I'm just gonna write
this thing and I don't care I'm also
saying I'm weddy and I love it because
sometimes reading too much can actually
stop you from adding anything new
because it's like everything's already
been said just like the best readers you
know are sort of like I'll never write a
book there's so many good things out
there I can't possibly write anything
like that right but the flip side of it
is like you do will never know how to
differentiate where you're adding value
if you don't know what other people are
saying yeah and I would get a base
knowledge of how to actually sell
something like knowing how Facebook
pixel works and like how doesn't you do
use a Facebook ad all of these things
are useful like I know all these people
making great content but it you know
it's just falling onto like 10 Twitter
followers distribution is like over 50
percent of the game yeah yeah you're so
right to say that and that's where the
platform matter is because I think
people make the mistake of thinking
marketers love this dream of repurposing
I'm gonna repurpose it on every platform
and if I actually know because what you
do what works on YouTube what works on
Soundcloud what works on Twitter what
works on Facebook they're all different
things yeah cool
all right last two questions what's your
most this for Medora what's your
favorite piece you've published already
gosh it's really really hard I will say
that there is a piece that stands out
for us as a flagship and I really
enjoyed working on it with the source
who is Kim Scott oh yeah who is you know
one of these people who is just a
majestic force in our industry and now
she's working on her own company based
on the story that initially ran on first
round like I'm not taking credit for
that obviously I know what piece you're
talking about love it's called a radical
candor and it was sort of the progenitor
of all the pieces that we then did
following it that relied on a framework
you know like a 2x2 here's a way to
clarify and crystallize your thinking
about something that would otherwise be
a muddy con
in your life yeah and in this story
she's talking about how to give feedback
which is always a gray area and fraught
with tension for a lot of folks and she
really did distill it into this format
that MIT gives you permission to give
people strong feedback that they can
actually use and it was just this bolt
out of the blue like new thinking on
management that is so rare and it just
for me became this beacon of what I try
to do as much as I possibly loved that
piece and we shared it around our time
among ourselves we already being read
the follow up because if you did one on
a gender version of that I loved it and
I think you nailed it that what made it
work is not just that it was new
thinking but that you had a framework
because that is what it takes is you
need something to people now print that
out and put it on their wall of their
office like that kind of thing that's
success that's a metric of success to me
for sure yeah I love that you said that
because I think a reign work gives it an
anchoring and I already mentioned that
my favorite piece which is what's our
favorites is yours our WeChat means that
Connie and I did but I would say that
the thing that what it didn't have a
framework it was an ethnographic piece
but my favorite thing about that piece
that I think made it work is that it
captures all the best tips for writing I
think actually if I were to give advice
to people because one of them one of the
things I used to do at Wired is we had
this I had this rule of thumb that I
learned the hard way on the opinion
section that you need to have at least
three turns of nuance because people the
first the classic
op-ed is like an argument like I believe
this and it's like that's really boring
and then you have another twist like you
said the kind of counterintuitive things
like but then that's also too obvious to
be counterintuitive because that's also
a stick then you get a converse exactly
and then yours your thing exactly so
then you got to flip it again and so I
used to always think about that and we
have that sort of like I always look for
that in depth of editing which is why I
am also partial to longer pieces but the
other thing is like there's a lot of
Show versus Tell in the gwee chat piece
because it's actually a real the whole
point of the piece is about what happens
when a [ __ ] when a country is mobile
native and leapfrog you know that the
the hardline era but you're using a very
specific instantiation we were even
deliberate like I kept probing with
Connie like okay but you're telling me
this story like what's an example of
connecting digital physical and
you get this story about this teddy bear
telling stories to a kid that's an image
you can relate to and so we're trying to
find as much specificity as possible and
I think that's my favorite piece because
it's so universal but so specific at the
same time like I love that and there's
just not that much of it right it's like
you said there are plenty of people who
have been CEOs or CEOs of companies that
never really did anything telling you
how to be a CEO like the Internet's long
on that but it's really short on these
specific examples of like crazy domain
knowledge yeah and that's why these like
weird niche sites that look like they're
from 1995 still like work yeah long tail
there's a reason it works yeah and the
long tail can become the head yeah
really good at it you can aggregate the
long tail into a head actually if you're
that can be the strategy for your
content effort mm-hmm to do that long
game alright last question what do you
read in your free time oh gosh it's not
gonna be at all inspiring to The Onion's
but I read a ton of historical
nonfiction okay so like the Wright
brothers or like you know team of rivals
that kind of stuff it's something that I
am bonded with my dad over but it's also
like for my writing a really interesting
way that like storytelling gets woven
through with the the rolling out of
facts you know like how can you leave
those things together in a way that's
really elegant and has cadence and
momentum and so it kind of keeps me
honest about how to write in that style
I love that I I don't have a fancy
answer I love fantasy novels and like
fiction like I love reading period and I
will read everything and I would
definitely describe myself as a
ridiculous info [ __ ] and I love Twitter
and I love reading every single thing I
can get my hands on and I have 20 books
in the air and my Kindle because that's
very mood based I actually collect like
organize my books by mood not by topic
and sometimes at any given time yeah the
thing that I will universally always
read and I love trashy novels and I just
like you need a little break in your
head and I love entertainment and I love
I love fantasy fiction it's like one of
my favorite genres and I just finished
like Sarah Moss's latest novel and it's
so damn good it's just I love that stuff
but I will and I would like to have some
nice message
influences my run but it actually
doesn't I don't think that was reaching
[Applause]
I actually don't see a direct connection
but I will say I do share that
philosophy from without women
I forgot any about Kirsten Dunst and
bring it on yeah member that movie the
cheerleader worried yeah it's on the
bring it and bring it on there's a scene
where they're trying to win the
competition and they start borrowing
influences from like jazz and and like
you know other drama and other fields
and bringing it together in theory I
mean that is a very interesting thing
that we should all be able to do and I
do read a lot of things that I think can
make you a better storyteller but I
don't see the direct map and yet good
writing is good writing yeah yeah what
about you Craig hey uh you smile when I
said fantasy you read a lot I love it
but I like I don't i think the the kick
that I'm on right now is physics
actually been a weird Laura valleys new
book no it's um it's a follow up of
seven principles and physics which is
also an excellent book by the way and
this is about quantum entanglement it's
so good yeah I just found it like I
actually there's an interview coming out
on the YC podcast relatively soon about
gravitational waves and yeah so it's
this guy Rana Adhikari from Caltech and
the guy behind the LIGO oh that's cool
but I realized when I'm because I met
him at a YC research conference and I
knew I wanted to do an interview
immediately and then when we set it up I
realized like oh [ __ ] like I'm in over
my head
so like that spiraled me into this like
reading all these books and listen about
guts and stuff and I've just been so
impressed with how physicists can
explain things and matter for and it
they like seem to be able to do it with
like capacity that exceeds almost every
other scientific field I don't know how
that happened I think because it's that
esoteric of a shield you need the
analogy and that's actually also why a
lot of physicists have written about
analogies like Doug Hofstadter wouldn't
count in that category but he has that
same ilk of person and he wrote that
book surfaces and essences on analogies
of the fuel and fire for it
I love that book but there's a lot of
stuff I totally agree with you yeah it's
like Neil deGrasse Tyson Richard Hyndman
like all of these people yeah and it
just works so yeah that's my that's my
thing right now I love that I think
there's a lot to be learned actually
from people following how scientists who
are writers right there's just so much
to learn there cuz I think that's what
our tech founders are there's a
scientist but of like bit different
types so perfect well let's end it right
there
[Applause]
you